hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about an aspect of fungal
structure called hyphy specifically
talking about three different kinds of
hyphy but in a septate hyphy Cohen a
senapathi and pseudo hyphy so first
let's talk about what what a hyphy what
hypr so the singular term for high C is
a haifa so that's the singular one haifa
it's a long branching filament we see
them in fungi and when we get many high
feet together that's how you spell high
feet plural so when you get many high
feet together they form this kind of
tangled mass that we call a mycelium so
now that we've established some of that
vocabulary let's start looking there are
three different kinds of hypee first we
have stepped a [ __ ] septic I fear those
that have cell walls between the
individual cells and these cells are
called septa and so if septa desorbing
at the terms that state they have these
cell walls that we call septa between
the individual cells and these these
septa have pores and them and these
pores are large enough for things to
move between them from one cell to
another so you can see here an example
of septate hyphy where we have the septa
separating individual cells but again
they've got these pores so things like
ribosomes mitochondria even nuclei can
actually move between cells and septate
hygiene and as you'll see the three
different types of hyphy we're
classifying them based on properties of
cell division and so here we have full
cell division although those pores are
present and our next type Koen acidic
sometimes pronounced seen acidic these
are also called ace
take a pee and that is because they lack
the septa so you can see in the drawing
here they completely lack any kind of
cell wall or cell membrane between the
cells and so these orange circles that
you see are the nuclei and whereas the
nuclei and the septic Heike were
separated by the septa here they're not
separated by anything and so they lack
those cell walls and some membranes and
so Co anesthetic or a septate hypee they
really function together they function
like a single unit multiple nuclei but
in a very coordinated fashion now let's
go on to talk about our third type and
that is pseudo hyphy pseudo hyphy is the
result of an incomplete budding type of
process so budding is how one yeast cell
will give rise to a daughter cell and so
in this process you'll have unicellular
yeast cells that actually stick together
following cell division so rather than
one cell a new cell budding off of an
old cell and then they become completely
separated instead they're sort of stuck
together still however there's no
cytoplasmic connection so with both a
septate and septate hyphy you haven't
this these connections between the
cytoplasm of the cells that doesn't
exist with stood oh hi pee so no
cytoplasmic connection you can see that
they're just kind of stuck together with
their cell walls but you couldn't have
things moving between the cells at least
not things like ribosomes in my
Andreea and so forth so if you want to
learn more about fungi please see my
video on introduction to fungi where you
can get a lot more information about
fungal structure and Mambo physiology
and thanks for watching biology
professor I'll see you next time